hi I'm John Phillips I'm Christina
Bonnington and Christina we made it back
from CES 2012 100% alive and intact it's
true it was a long week you're kind of
sick I'm back I am sick but we're ready
to show some of the best videos from the
show the first one is the Lumia 900
which you reviewed checked out let's
take a look here we are at CES 2012 with
the Nokia Lumia 900 it's one of two new
windows phones debuting on AT&T this
year the Nokia Lumia 900 is slightly
larger than its sister than Lumia 800
which came out in 2011 it's got a 4.3
inch AMOLED screen inside it's got a 1.4
megahertz Qualcomm processor since
everyone loves taking pictures with
their smart phone the Lumia 900 has an
8-megapixel rear-facing camera with a
Carl Zeiss lens on the front it's got a
1 megapixel camera the Lumia 900 looks a
lot like the Lumia 800 it's got a
similar form factor on the side it's got
a volume rocker a power button and a
shutter button for the camera the Lumia
900 runs windows phone mango and it'll
be out sometime in the next few months
so that was the Lumia 900 there is
another windows phone that you talk as
well yes the HTC Titan too has a 16
megapixel camera it's big and it's the
other big windows phone of the show and
so another video we want to show you is
John Bradley who's the senior editor of
Wired print magazine and he's going to
be trying out these centex goggles
essentially it's a virtual reality
goggles system and he looks pretty
trippy trying them out
we're here at CES at digital experience
a press event for the show and this
thing on my head is called smart goggles
it's a virtual reality helmet right now
I'm playing a game in which I'm a robot
smashing a city I can jump up and smash
buildings it's an android-powered unit
there's actually a 1.2 gigahertz android
device in the helmet here and these
little circles in front aren't
decorative they're actually motion
sensors you can use your hands to
interact with the games as more games
become available this is kind of a proof
of concept prototype but the company
actually hopes to bring this to market
by the end of the year for under a
thousand dollars and I gotta say it's
it's pretty fun they're kind of heavy
they're a little hot I can't hear that
well but I'm smashing a building and I
mean that's really all that matters that
was cool didn't I hear that John kind of
broke that when he took it off that's
right I heard that a piece flew off as
he was removing the prototype but its
prototype technology not his fault and
these things happen at CES the next
video is Christina I guess you would say
demoing the loudest ipod dock in the
world
this is a ton of music literally it
weighs almost a thousand pounds this is
the I nuke boom it's a thirty thousand
dollar ipod dock from behringer who's
been making audio products for over
twenty years inside it's got a lot of
cool tech including two custom-made dual
18 inch subwoofers it'll blow girls
clothes off this thing pumps out 10,000
watts of power at 131 decibels it's like
having Motorhead in your living room if
you want to put this much boom in your
room it's gonna cost you thirty thousand
dollars iphone not included so wait a
second do I have this right you said it
will blow girls clothes off that's what
they told me we did not try that out on
the show floor although I did have to
take my shoes off shoes and socks off to
sit on me speaker donnie um so I guess
we got part of the way they're very
controversial Christina next up is
another goofy product it's a Spearow
robot ball that you control with your
iPhone at CES it's no surprise to find
the latest coolest gadgets things like
tablet PCs ereader zor networked home
appliances but we're pretty sure we
found the coolest gadget that will drive
your cat's absolutely insane it's called
the Spiro and it works because as a
3-axis accelerometer inside of it pretty
much the same one that you would find
inside of your iPhone or wii remote and
it works basically by putting it down on
the ground and use your iOS device or
Android device to remotely navigate it
through pretty much anything a series of
cones you can do it up a ramp and the
developers in Spiro have also included
both created an SDK which will allow you
to create your own apps to pretty much
make the Sphero do whatever you want
there's also included some games with it
golfing game a driving game
and in February they'll be releasing a
Simon like game volvik colors as well as
a space fighter game called you guessed
it space fighter now the sparrow is
available at go sparrow calm and it
retails for 129 dollars remember to
drive your cats absolutely insane it's
worth every penny so I actually got to
check out this Bureau robot ball
recently but my cat is too fat and lazy
and I ended up just kind of rolling the
ball into her while she laid all round
well you know it's waterproof too and so
if you had a duck your duck could enjoy
it as well in the water so finally we
want to get into this attachment for
your iphone it's a panoramic lens
attachment and Mike Isaac is the one
demo here hey guys we're here at CES
2012 now I know you've seen a
million-in-one iphone camera lenses this
is actually a pretty cool one the coach
at ODOT actually films in 360° panoramic
view h point 264 codec so you can
basically share any of your videos shot
completely 360 around you so I put this
on the ground I lay it in the middle of
my floor and I can see my parents you
know sitting on the couch and my cat
across the room crawling on the
windowsill at the same time it's gonna
be everywhere pretty soon in Apple
stores and online on amazon com as well
as Apple online for 80 bucks which is
not terribly pricey for for an iphone
wins it's new it's different its kind of
funky and you can shoot video in a weird
way that that I haven't before so I knew
Mike had a roommate but I didn't realize
it was his parents curious neither did I
so that wraps up the gadget lab podcast
for this week go to gadget lab to check
out more stories and videos of CES and
we'll be back next week at this time
you